(gentle electronic music)
- So let me just begin
What Can Physics Say About Life.
So let me get around to the brass tacks.
I don't wanna disappoint
you, but I was gonna quote
one of my heroes, Richard Feynman.
He says, everything that
is living can be understood
in terms of the jigglings
and wiggling of atoms.
Now, that may be true,
but this is a big jump
between atoms wiggling and
jiggling and real life.
And to drive that point home,
I'm gonna quote another physicist.
And this was said after he
wrote a very famous equation,
and after he just wrote
that down, he said,
the general theory of quantum mechanics
is now almost complete.
The underlying physical laws necessary
for the mathematical theory
of a large part of chemistry
and the whole, a large part of physics
and the whole of chemistry are thus known.
The difficulty is only
that the exact application
of these laws leads to
equations that are much
too complicated to be soluble.
So therein lies the problem.
When you look at a complicated
system, our fundamental laws
of physics, quantum
mechanics, can't even begin
to describe something from
basic fundamental laws.
It becomes much too
complicated much too quickly.
And so keep this in mind,
and I will try to return
to that at the end of the lecture.
So most of what we know
in chemistry and biology
has been determined by bulk studies.
And if you could look at
things happening one at a time,
molecules, biological reactions
happening one at a time,
could you see something different?
And to try to perk your imagination,
suppose you were on Mars and
you had a special telescope
that could measure something
like the average number
of legs on a organism.
And you happen to be looking
at the zoo, San Francisco Zoo,
and you find that the average is 3.7.
Now this is puzzling because
on Mars, the creatures
have four legs and six legs and eight legs
and two legs and some have
no legs, but never 3.7.
Not to worry, because your
theoretical physicist friend
explains why it's natural to be 3.7.
But if you then looked and
could look at individual animals
then you'd realize a very different thing.
And there is a supposition
in our own brains
that if we look at simple
systems like individual atoms
or molecules, they're all
the same, they're identical,
and they should behave
in very similar ways.
And so the average becomes
really what is happening.
And quite often the
average has nothing to do
with what is happening.
So my tack on this is again,
as not a deep theoretical
physicist, but as an experimentalist.
I wanna quote the great
American philosopher
of the 20th century, Yogi Berra,
who said you can see a lot by watching.
And so if you have new instrumentation
and new ways of looking at things,
maybe you can stumble on something.
Okay, what's the new way?
Well, when I was at Bell
Laboratories, we developed methods
to manipulate atoms and
also microscopic particles.
And when I came to Stanford,
shortly after I came
to Stanford, I set about
saying, well, if we can hold on
to micron-sized spheres and
things on the scale of
an atom with laser light,
why not try to hold on
to individual molecules?
And so I worked with a an MD PhD student
who taught me a little molecular biology
so I could start gluing
polystyrene spheres onto DNA.
I worked with other colleagues.
Jim Spudich in the Medical
School, Bob Simmons,
a biophysicists from King's College London
to do some force experiments
on watching a single molecule
of myosin pull on a single actin filament.
And so at least from my
point of view, this said,
okay, it looks like it's
going to be a lot of fun.
So I'm gonna tell you
now about two things,
little short stories that
have come out of my lab.
One is the cleavage, that
cleavage is a word that means
cut RNA by a particular enzyme
called a hairpin ribozyme.
Ribozyme, now, to my physicist friends,
don't be too scared of these words.
They are just invented to keep
physicists in their place.
(audience laughing)
So I will try to explain the words to you,
and I tried to cull out most of them.
But ribozyme means it's
an RNA, a piece of RNA
that acts as an enzyme.
What's an enzyme, an enzyme
is like a chemical catalyst.
It makes a biological reaction occur
at roughly a billion,
10 billion times faster
than it normally would occur.
So enzymes are very important.
Without enzymes, biological
reactions, meaning biological
or most biological reactions
would simply not happen.
And proteins are enzymes, many
proteins serve as enzymes,
and in 1980, it was discovered that RNA
could also serve as an enzyme.
And that has made big
news, and they're looking
more and more important as time goes by.
So I'm gonna describe an RNA enzyme,
and I'm gonna describe
something that I'm sure
many of you have heard of,
and that is the machine
that actually makes the proteins
by reading messenger RNA.
All right, so this is a
schematic of this simple enzyme.
It's in green and blue, and
these letters are the bases.
So it's RNA, it's like DNA,
very similar structure,
there's bases and there's a backbone.
And the AAUAG are simply the bases,
and the enzyme itself is actually
the green and blue parts,
and this particular thing,
it's only 50 bases long.
It's a teeny little enzyme.
And what it does is it attaches
to another piece of RNA
very specifically, so it
notices there's a specific
base pair sequence, and
it attaches to this,
and it cuts it, and that's all it does.
In fact, but that's an important process
because RNA enzymes now we
know do a lot of splicing
and dicing of messenger RNA
after it's been transcribed.
Now because it actually is specific,
it can identify a very
specific piece of RNA,
people are beginning to
think maybe you can engineer
an enzyme like this to recognize
a particularly destructive
piece of RNA that you wanna
get to denature in some way.
And so people are thinking
about designing these things
to cut HIV viruses.
But let me just tell you
the basic idea of this.
This structure of this part and this part,
these are little short
stubs of double helices,
and this bubble over here
means that the the bases
aren't making bonafide
Watson-Crick base pairs,
and so they're kinda dangling about.
This thing folds into
itself, and this is a cartoon
of these helices folding into
itself, and when it does that,
there's a chemical reaction
occurs when these backbones
are in close proximity, and
there's a cut made here.
I don't want to describe the chemistry
mostly because I don't know it that well.
But just to say this is
understood, when you put
the backbones close together,
this enzyme could either
cut the backbone of the RNA,
or it can join it together.
It's completely reversible.
If you have two pieces
that are broken and born,
but yeah, they can join it.
Otherwise, it can cut it.
Okay, now
this experiment was actually
done in our early days
when we were actually trying to do a proof
of principle experiments,
and a biologist, Nils Walter
from Michigan had heard me give a talk,
and he approached me and
said, well, the techniques
you're developing, maybe you
can help with my problem.
And his problem is to understand
how this little enzyme
cuts this piece of RNA.
And so we looked at it, and I said, sure,
we can measure these rates.
And these are some of the questions
that we were thinking we could measure.
All right, so it's very simple.
What we did is we're
gonna use the technique,
it's actually an old
technique invented in 19,
well, actually applied to biology in 1967,
invented in the '40s by a physicist.
And that is, you have a
dye molecule over here,
and you excited with let's say blue light.
And normally this molecule
emits in the green.
But if you put this molecule
next to another molecule
that normally absorbs in the
green but emits in the red,
what you can have is what
we call energy transfer,
namely the energy of the
light goes into this molecule,
the energy in this
molecule gets transferred
to this molecule, and
then you see red light
if the two molecules are
sufficiently close together.
So by looking at the ratio
of red to green light,
you can find out how close these molecules
are to each other at a molecular scale.
And it turns out that
there's a very steep falloff,
so when they're very close,
you see mostly red light.
When they're very far
away, so their red molecule
has no effect, you see mostly green light.
And in this middle over
here at a distance scale
of five nanometers, you
can see some mixture
of red and green.
And in fact, by looking in
the change in relative color
between red and green, you
can actually measure distances
less than 10 angstroms.
So this can be a spectroscopic ruler
by just looking at the ratio of colors.
Okay, so this is a wonderful technique,
and so we thought why not try it.
It's very simple, you put
a red and green molecule
on this thing, and so when
this enzyme is standing
up straight, you excite mostly green light
and you see mostly green light.
When it's in this so-called dock position,
you excite the green molecule,
but you see mostly red light.
And when the piece of, the
other piece of RNA falls off,
this becomes very flexible
so that on average,
its average distance is dictated
by this stiff double helix.
And so you see intermediate red and green.
The idea is very simple.
We just put a lot of these
molecules on a microscope slide,
we come in in a with a laser
and excite it with green light.
Then we simply look with
an optical microscope.
There's some very simple
optics that divides
the image into a green
image and a red image,
and we just project the two images
onto a very sensitive camera.
So it's very low-tech, it's
just in an optical microscope,
a pretty expensive camera,
and the only other thing
you'll have to worry
about is that it has to be
fairly clean and you can't get a lot of,
get rid of all the stuff that fluoresces.
Okay, one other thing we
added at the time that was new
is that we wanted to put
reagents into the molecules.
And so we wanted to pin the
molecules onto the surface.
So once the molecules were
loosely pinned to the surface,
we can flow reagents across the molecules,
and we can expose our
molecules to different things.
So in this case, what do we see?
We see that this molecule
is flipping back and forth.
And so this is an actual
raw data of the intensity
of the green and red light
from a single enzyme.
And so what's happening
is when the green is high,
it's standing up straight,
and when the red is high,
it's folded into this
position where you get
a lot of energy transfer.
And so you see that it's very good signals
of it flopping back and
forth between red high
and green high, and
this is real-time data,
and just flopping around.
But you notice something.
This one molecule here
spends very little time
in the red high state,
another very short time in
the red high state, and so on.
This one spends some intermediate time
in the red high state, this
one is spending a lot of time
in the docked state, the red high state.
Occasionally you see
transitions between the two.
But for the most part,
they seem to remember
what they did last.
So if they spent a lot of
time the docked stated,
it undocks, and comes back.
And it turns out if you
plot out, you make a graph
of all the times it
spends in these states,
what you find is the time it
takes this upright molecule
to fold into one of these
dock states is a constant,
it's well-described by a
single exponential, the k.
No surprises here.
But once it's in the dock
state, there appear to be
very distinct classes of
times which it would take to
stand up straight again.
And you can see this clear
because they're different colors.
But really they were
well-separated and roughly
an order of magnitude
difference in the rate, okay?
So this was very peculiar, because first,
why do they have different states?
Well, that was an easy thing.
It turned out that as the
thing came and docked,
it would form a different
number of hydrogen bonds,
and we could show this by
actually making point mutations
on this molecule and
defeat some of the bases,
the hydrogen bonds that
the bases would make.
And then we would change everything,
and it seemed to scale right.
So we said, okay, not so surprising.
It's making different hydrogen bonds.
But it was remembering what it was doing.
So here is one of the simplest RNA enzymes
there is around, and it has
a reasonably good memory.
It would remember for about an hour
before it would lose memory.
This was quite a surprise.
I should say that we're
not completely sure
what the cause of the memory is,
but I'm using the word
memory because it really is
non-Markovian, it really remembered,
if it spends a long time here,
the next time it comes down,
it's gonna spend a long time there.
And that's what we call memory.
And it must be that there's
some other thing flipping around
in perhaps a stochastic
way, but it's much slower
than the time it takes
to dock and undock, okay?
So I wanna take some of
the mystery out of it.
But it was a surprise.
And this is something that
people did not expect to see.
There is a lot of things
going on in biology
that have seemed to have some hysteresis.
But I wanna point out something else.
Here you have one piece of RNA,
and this enzyme cuts it
into two pieces, all right?
Now this is a covalent bond.
And so you need to supply some net energy
to cut this covalent bond.
And so what we found when
we measured the rates
of this enzymatic
reaction, that yes indeed
it does take net energy.
In order to cut this in half,
you have to supply energy.
That means the cut piece of
RNA, you've got your intact RNA,
you've gotta go up over some
hump maybe, but in the end,
the equilibrium position is
that you have to supply energy.
But this enzyme doesn't burn
any fuel to cut it, okay?
And the reason is this
enzyme has gone to school
and knows about statistical
mechanics and thermodynamics.
And it knows that it's not the
energy, like the heat energy
that you normally think
of, but it's what's called
a free energy, which is the heat energy,
the enthalpic energy, minus
something that has to do with S,
the entropy, the amount of disorder.
And so what happens is normally systems,
if they're naturally gonna relax,
they go to states of lower energy.
Balls rolling down hills,
that's the natural state of affairs.
You don't need to burn
energy to have a ball
roll down a hill.
And if you're not burning
the energy, that means
you must be going downhill in free energy.
And what is happening
fundamentally is that two pieces
of RNA in solution have more
entropy, considerably more
entropy than one piece, and
that increase in entropy
is actually more than
the net energy you need
to break the hydrogen bond.
So this enzyme says I
don't need to use fuel.
I can break this covalent
bond because you're gonna gain
so much in entropy, you'll be all right.
All right?
Now if you pose that as a design problem
to an engineer and said, I
don't wanna burn any energy
because the free energy
is higher for two pieces,
how would you do it?
Now let's go back and look.
What is it doing?
It comes and binds, this
piece of RNA comes and binds,
and it goes into this dock position.
And what we found from
our measurements is once
it's in its dock position,
it's twice as likely
to join the two pieces
than to break 'em, okay?
That means you need
net energy to break it.
And what is it doing?
If it happens to break
this piece and it undocks,
well, they originally were
joined by 10 base pairs.
When it undocks, there's
one piece joined by six,
one piece joined by four.
At the thermal temperatures
this thing operates at,
body temperature, and the time it stays
in the undocked position, those
two little pieces fly off.
They're not bound as well,
and they just fly off.
The enzymatic reaction is done.
If it didn't happen and
there's still one piece,
it goes back and tries again.
And each time there's a probability of 1/3
that they will cut it, it goes up.
So you take 2/3, raise it to the n power,
and you find that you've
done your reaction.
So the reason it's flopping
back and forth like that,
in fact, the times that it
takes to flop back and forth
look very nice because
in a few cycles of this,
it's done its thing, it
hasn't burned any energy.
Everything is reversible, but
it's taking full advantage
of this disorder, the entropy.
Okay, so you look back at
this little simple enzyme,
and the moral here is
this is pretty smart.
Now we see why it's flopping around,
and you can actually begin
to understand the rates.
All right, so emboldened,
we decided to go ahead
and look at even crazier problems.
And so I wanna remind you of
the central dogma of biology
in very important calligraphy.
So here we have the DNA,
and this as you all know,
the base pair sequence
contains all the information
about your genetic makeup.
And there is an enzyme that transcribes,
if you want to make a particular protein,
there's an enzyme that goes to this DNA
and unravels a little bit of
it and makes a mirror copy
of one strand of the DNA called RNA.
That's a wonderful enzyme
called RNA polymerase.
There's huge amounts of
study of how this thing
actually works, what
tells it when to start
and stop and things like that.
But then this message, the messenger RNA,
then goes into another
machine and makes proteins.
And this machine reads
this message, so for every
three bases, it looks around, say,
UUA, some base sequence.
So what's the amino acid
that corresponds to UUA?
Oh, there it is, pop it in.
What's the next message,
there it is, pops it in.
And so it translates the base pair message
into a string of amino acids.
The string of amino acids
fold into a protein.
And these are, for the most part,
the magical enzymes that make life happen.
So I wanna study how this
machine actually works.
So here's a picture, five
angstrom picture of this machine.
So these purple things
and these dark blue things
are proteins, the light
blue and the gray things
are pieces of RNA.
These red things in here are transfer RNA.
This little squiggle in
here is the messenger RNA.
This is a five angstrom structure of this.
Now we're gonna peel back
and look at this object
without the RNA.
And it's very nice because
you see right here,
the tips over here,
that's the transfer RNA
are holding the amino acids.
So they're looking, this transfer RNA,
for every amino acid,
there is a unique base
corresponding to that amino acid.
And the toe of this RNA is playing footsie
with this messenger RNA.
And if there's a match
here, then this enzyme says,
okay, that's the right amino acid.
Put that into this growing
chain of amino acids.
One of the things I should point out
is there's no proteins around in the core
where these amino acids are being joined.
So in this sense, this
enzyme is also an RNA enzyme,
one of these most
essential features, namely,
linking the amino acids together
is done by RNA.
Okay, so we want to understand
how this thing really works.
Okay, so the overall
scheme of the transfer RNA
is going in and linking amino acids,
was developed 40 years ago.
But the mechanism has remained a mystery.
There have been a new genetic biochemical
and kinetic experiments,
and you'll be hearing
now today about some new
single molecule experiments
that we have been doing.
So I need to tell you a
little bit of background.
RNA, the amino acids enter in what we call
a ternary complex, this
fancy word means three parts.
What's the first part,
it's the transfer RNA.
And this is the thing
that's gonna play footsie
with the messenger RNA.
So these dashes here are the
bases to see if it's a match.
There's this blue thing
here, that's a protein.
That has a fancy name,
elongation factor Tu.
And it's a catalyst, it's an enzyme.
And it makes the insertion
of the right amino acid
occur much faster, and
we'll see a little bit later
how that occurs.
And of course the most
important thing, the amino acid,
and that you can't see in this picture.
It's behind this blue thing.
All right, so what happens?
This is now an atomic structure.
It's a fake thing you can
get actually off the web.
You can get the coordinates
and there are programs,
and you can actually make
these pretty pictures.
But this is the ribosome.
This dash thing is where
the messenger RNA is.
And here's a transfer RNA
and here's another one.
And suppose you want to
make a protein chain.
Well, this thing comes along
and this protein over here
sticks to another protein on the ribosome,
and all the amino acids carrying,
all the ternary complexes will stick.
And so it's a general sort
of faintly sticky thing
and then it checks, am I the right one,
by checking the base pairs, right?
And if it is right, then what happens
through a sequence of steps,
this thing incorporates in
and a peptide is form, a
peptide bond is formed,
two amino acids are linked together.
After that, they kind of
start to straddle over.
Another mystery step occurs
where another object,
another protein comes along and nudges it,
so this is in a so-called P site
and this is in the E or exit site,
and then this thing
flies off and it's reset,
and it's ready to accept another one.
So what happens in this
process is you start this,
initiate it, and every time
the a ternary complex goes in,
is it the right one, if not, it rejects.
If it's the right one, it says okay,
make the amino acid link go through here.
You're burning units of
fuel, two units of fuel.
And it goes round and round again, resets,
and goes round around until
it finally gets to a message
where it doesn't code for an amino acid,
and it says time to stop, and there it is.
So this is how you make proteins.
This work was done in
collaboration with Jody Puglisi,
the structural biology
department at Stanford.
And it started with Scott
Blanchard and Harold Kim,
two graduate students, later
joined by Ruben Gonzalez,
who is a graduate student here.
And Scott finally graduated and is now
a postdoc in my group.
And okay, so now I'm gonna
focus on just one question.
How does it actually pick
the right amino acid?
Well, it does it very well.
It's error rate is only
one part in a thousand
to one part in 10,000.
Now if you look at this,
and the way I was taught
in high school biology, you say, well,
it's because of the bases.
If the bases are a
complement to each other
and if it's a right match,
that's a good chemical bond,
and so it sticks around
longer, and so it'll accept it.
If it's one of the bases doesn't match,
you don't have as many chemical
bonds, it will fly off.
So that's good, so let's
examine that in some detail.
There's some series of
spectacular experiments
that were done by Wolfgang
Wintermeyer and his colleagues
and what they found, and
their basic experiment is
they would put a dye
molecule on the transfer RNA,
and as the transfer RNA
goes into the ribosome,
there's a little bit of
flexing of the transfer RNA.
And for whatever reason
that's not understood,
the amount of light this dye
molecule emits is changed.
Not by much, five or 10%.
But if you look at a whole bunch of them,
what you can find is that it
goes into different states,
and they look at the time
dependence of how the light,
the amount of light is changing.
And from that and other
techniques, they were able
to actually build together a model for how
this is really making
its decision process.
And that plus other experiments
that others have done.
And what they found was
here's our ribosome,
this yellow thing is that
protein, so it sticks
to the ribosome, it checks,
am I the right one or not.
If I am the right one,
it goes forward and goes
into another state signaled by a change
in the amount of light.
And if it's the right one, it goes forward
at a rate of 500 per second.
If it's the wrong one, it
goes forward 10 times slower.
The good news is if it's the wrong one,
there's a one base mismatch,
so if two of the bases match,
but the first one didn't match,
it rejects a hundred times faster
than if it's the right message.
So this is perfectly what you want.
This is doing the right thing.
The blue guys are the wrong one,
the red guys are the right
ones, it's going fast.
However, the next step occurred so fast
that it didn't matter.
If whether it's the right
one of the wrong one,
it was so fast compared
to the rejection rates
that no matter what was incorporated,
his measurements told
him it was happening,
and the ratio was only 1.07
to one right to wrong, okay?
Then afterwards he found
that the only real selection
was done later, much
later, where he was getting
a selection of about 1%.
And he could measure when
the peptide bond was formed.
Now to be fair, he realized
that this was contrary
to what was measured in E. coli
by a bunch of orders of magnitude.
But he said, well, we know something.
I had to do my experiments
at high concentration
of magnesium, and we know that if we put
E. coli in high
concentrations of manganese,
they make many more mistakes.
An order of magnitude more
when you go by only a factor
two in magnesium concentration.
And he was up by that factor
of two, so he said, well,
at least an order of
magnitude was due to that,
and maybe that's why we didn't
see the first selection.
Okay, so we decided we wanted to play,
and so here's our ribosome,
here's our transfer RNA
with our little green dye on the elbow.
And we put in another transfer
RNA with a little red dye
on an elbow of the RNA.
So the amino acid is up here
at the tip of my finger,
the feet that's gonna check
the bases are down here
by my thumb, and the dye is
right there on my knuckle.
And if this thing incorporates into this
machine, you're gonna see some color.
So let me show you the raw data
to give you an appreciation.
So here are these spots.
Each spot for the most
part, besides from dirt,
is a single dye molecule
attached on to the tRNA
on a ribosome, so one dot of light
is one ribosome on our surface.
And in this field of
view, this is seen through
a green filter, and this
field of view is seen
through a red filter.
The same field of view,
but the red filter.
And so we start the clock,
and we start throwing in
transfer RNA with the red
dye, and this fuzz around here
is the dye weakly being
excited by our green laser.
But occasionally you see what's
happening, there's beginning
to appear more and more
of these spots of light.
And when these spots of light,
this one would correspond
to this one over here, you find
that the ratio of the colors
red and green are changing, okay?
So what we did is we float
in some transfer RNA.
Here's our message on our messenger RNA.
When we float is some
transfer RNA that was
the right match, it was
absolutely the right thing,
and we wanted to compare
that to a near match
where we kept the same transfer RNA,
but we changed the message.
So instead of the first
one being a U, it's a C.
And so you would make
two things over here,
and this one you would
only make, it's a weak one.
So this one has two bonds,
two bonds plus a weak,
what's called a wobble pair,
so it's effectively like one.
This is effectively two,
four, six, six hydrogen bonds.
And this is two plus
one, three, four, okay.
It's a little different but not much.
But the difference is spectacular.
This is a single time trace
looking now at the rate applied
on the y-axis is a ratio of
red light to total light.
And here's one pops in, and
you immediately begin to see
more and more here it's all green light.
Here you begin to see
more and more red light.
It might pause a little bit here.
And it goes up into the
state wobbling around.
And we showed in other experiments
that once it's up here,
it's actually formed the peptide bond.
I don't wanna tell you that detail.
This thing here is a technical
flaw in our experiment.
One of the molecules,
it's a single molecule,
and they sometimes blink
off, they go to sleep
for a little while and they pop back up.
And we don't know why it
is, we wish it'd go away.
But we're gonna focus on here in the first
few hundred milliseconds, and
so this type of stuff is okay.
So this is when we put in the right tRNA
with the right message.
This is one where we put in the same tRNA
but the wrong message, and
we see blip, blip, blip.
These are separate
events, because remember,
there's all this transfer RNA
flowing around the solution.
If we wash that out, these blips go away.
So we think each blip is a
let's play footsie, check, nope,
you're not the one I should
be dating, you're out, okay?
Now you put hundreds of
these onto a timescale,
and what you see is here
you float in the things
so the baseline changes.
And then this scattered thing
here is these little blips.
But if you put in the right
thing, it looks pretty good.
But this is the absolute wrong way
you wanna analyze the data.
Because what you wanna do
is for each time trace,
once it passes a certain
threshold, you say,
let's start the clock then.
You don't wanna start the clock
when you threw in the solution.
You wanna do that when you're working with
a billion molecules all at once,
but we're working with one at a time.
So the point here is that
because you have the time record
of each individual molecule,
you can synchronize
at any point you want.
And when you do that, you
get this pretty picture.
So once you're above threshold
for the one base mismatch,
you see that most of them
just dump immediately.
Some of 'em straggle up a little higher.
For the correct tRNA, you
see that instead of dumping,
they go maybe into some other state.
Don't know on this one.
And then it goes up in this high state,
which we showed in earlier
experiments, that yes,
we've actually formed that peptide bond.
And this stuff here is
an onset of this blinking
that we wish would go away.
So we're gonna now explore
what's happening here
and compare it to what's happening here.
So for the first thing you can do, oh,
just looking at this raw data,
you said yes, this is selecting something.
And in the first stage
of selection, we found
that it's in fact there was some selection
in this first stage,
it's about seven to one.
We were at slightly higher
magnesium concentration
than Wolfgang Wintermeyer,
a factor of two even higher.
The reason why we see selection
they don't, we believe,
is because their probe
confused two different states
with a single state.
And then what they do is they do a mass
rate equation fit to that.
And so they were, since their
probe didn't actually see
two different states, they missed it,
so they were doing best that they could.
And so it's really two states.
In fact, this is crucial for interpreting
really what's going on.
Okay, now let's look in more
detail at what's going on.
We can put in the right
transfer RNA into the ribosome
with an antibiotic called tetracycline.
Now you all know about antibiotics.
In fact, many of you
have had tetracycline.
It turns out there are
over 200 antibiotics
that are used to kill E.
coli and other bacteria,
mostly other bacteria.
You don't really wanna kill your E. coli,
but other bacteria, and
they attack the ribosome.
These 200 antibiotics attacked the machine
because it's such a vital part
of the life of a bacteria.
If you make this machine
not work, the bacteria die.
What does tetracycline do?
Well, we found out what it
does is it stops the advance
of this transfer RNA into the ribosome
at the very first step.
And at this point, even
if it's the right message,
they dump, okay, whether
it's the near miss
or they're hit, it dumps.
And so that first step is
really a bonafide state, okay?
Well, there's also
another part of this thing
when the transfer RNA comes in.
There's a unit of fuel in this.
You're gonna break a phosphate bond.
In biology, the coin of the
realm in terms of energy
is phosphate bonds, you
break a phosphate bond,
you release some chemical energy,
use that to do something.
And in the accommodation process,
you're breaking a phosphate bond.
So what we can do is we can
put in the transfer RNA,
the ternary complex, but with
a pre-burned unit of fuel.
Instead of GTP with three
phosphates, triphosphate,
we're gonna put in GDP, diphosphate, NP.
And so the bond's already broken.
But by and large, it looks
essentially the same.
Very different.
It goes from that initial 0.35 state
and it stalls here at 0.5.
Okay, so you haven't gotten to the point
where you burned anything yet, and you see
that this thing was a bonafide
state, this 0.5 state.
The 0.5 is half of it
red, half of it green.
And once it's in this 0.5
state, it lingers there
for a very long period of time.
In fact, about a factor
of 30 longer than before.
So what's the mechanism for selection?
Now you need to know some
facts, some structural facts.
And so this came out.
There was a hint of it
in 1999 by Jody Puglisi
in our work, but it came
out in glorious detail
in 2001 with Ramakrishnan.
And what he did is he looked
at the atomic structure
of the bottom part of the ribosome
that's accepting the tRNA.
And he looked at that structure
and he found the structure
of the bottom part with the tRNA in it.
And what he found was
that this thing closed in
around the base of the tRNA.
So in addition to having
a base pair match,
this thing reacted by
closing in a little tighter
and gripped it a little bit.
So there were additional
chemical contacts, okay.
Another thing which you
just saw in our data,
once it's, if it's a right
message, and once it goes
into this other state before
its burned a unit of fuel,
it's now stable, it's gonna linger around
for a long period of time,
so the selection process must be over.
Okay, so we, and one other
fact, another structural fact
that came out 2002 was
after it's stabilized,
it turns out the transfer RNA
is being held at the bottom
where the bases are, and
it's being held up here
with another loop on the ribosome,
and there's a chemical
contact of one loop of RNA
on the ribosome to this
thing, this protein.
So there's a little loop
called a sarcin-ricin loop
that's now thrown itself
on this little protein
and it's made a chemical contact.
So this thing is bound
here and bound here.
And it's bound there after
GTP hydrolysis, okay.
So now we're gonna make a little leap.
It's not much of a leap.
This thing comes in and plays footsie.
And because it's playing
footsie, if it's the right match,
we know from structural
data that it closes in.
Well, if it's gonna
close in, what do we see?
We see that when it goes from 0.35 to 0.5,
it's actually moving closer
in to where it should be.
That's from our FRET data.
And so it's actually rotating.
Remember, a dye molecule is on this elbow,
and it's rotating this dye molecule closer
to another dye molecule
located about here.
Okay, so it goes from
this point to this point
just based on the fact
that the bottom part
has now wrapped itself around the bottom.
And we know from our FRET
data it's rotating closer.
Now it actually doesn't
smash it up against
this loop of RNA, this
sarcin-ricin loop immediately.
How do we know this, because
it takes 50 milliseconds
to complete this reaction, okay?
So it's held there, it's a little closer,
but it still needs a big
thermal fluctuation to attach.
Now as a physicist, you'd look at this
and say that makes great
sense, because what it's done
is the minuscule or no chemical
reaction difference here
is amplified by the
reaction of the bottom part.
So you make additional
contacts if the shape is right.
But it does something
even better than that.
It's gonna magnify that a little more
because if the shape
is right it torques it,
but it torques it not all the
way because it still needs
a gigantic thermal fluctuation to link it,
50 milliseconds worth of
a gigantic fluctuation.
That makes it highly improbable.
That puts the probability
up in the exponent.
So if it's not the right shape,
it doesn't quite torque it enough.
So you've now had a
compounding of probabilities
all put in the exponent.
This, we believe, is the
first stage of selection.
And it also very clearly seems to suggest
what was before a very
big mystery to this.
This molecule, the ribosome's big.
It's 200 angstroms in size.
The transfer RNA is 90
angstroms in length.
So the biologists said, how could this be?
Something's happening
down here at the foot,
and then you're making an additional cut,
and we know GTP hydrolysis
is occurring here
some 60 angstroms away.
How is this knowledge
communicated up here?
Is this some mysterious
way through the body
of the ribosome, or is it
through the transfer RNA?
And we now know from our FRET measurement
that it's just rotating closer together,
that it just simply getting it more likely
to touch the sarcin-ricin loop.
So that's what we call, or
what the biologists call
an allosteric reaction, seems
to be an action in a distance.
So what's the real mechanism?
Well, what happens after GTP hydrolysis?
Well, what we know, again from structure,
is after GTP hydrolysis,
which is by the way occurring
right here on this, right at that point,
this protein falls away.
Now we don't know, but it's
likely that if that protein
falls away, this contact
is greatly weakened,
and maybe it snaps back
into that rotated position.
That's if it's the right fit.
If it's the wrong fit it actually
rotates even further away.
And so what appears to be happening
is that after GTP hydrolysis
and this thing is released,
Hopfield was dead-on right.
You're testing the bottom
reaction again, okay?
He was invoking GTP hydrolysis, remember,
to make it irreversible,
and he suggested maybe
you tested it once on the
way in, after GTP hydrolysis,
you test it again, and if it works,
then you fully accommodate.
So we think he's right.
He was being tested again.
It's mostly shape though, it
wasn't energy, bond energy.
But there's something even
better, and the last thing,
again, a structural piece of information
from the atomic resolution data.
When the tRNA is really in
there and it's about to make
the peptide bond form, it's
bound here at the base.
It's also bound right near the amino acid,
right just before that, and a little loop,
another loop of RNA on the
ribosome called the A-loop.
And by looking at the atomic
resolution of the upper part
of the ribosome, remember, you can't get
atomic resolution of the whole thing.
The atomic resolution in
the upper part, you find
that when tRNA is bound to it,
this A-loop is sticking out
and making contacts with this tRNA.
So it's changing shape
in order to make contact.
So you might think, well, isn't that cozy.
Before this tRNA can actually go in fully,
something's gotta happen over here.
It's gotta change shape
to allow final binding
to stabilize the tRNA,
otherwise it's held down here.
So you might think is the energy released.
In GTP hydrolysis, you have
some energy you can burn.
Maybe you can make some mechanical motion
to change that A-loop.
So we looked at the following,
we took our ribosome,
there's a chemical you
can use that actually cuts
that sarcin-ricin loop
at a very specific spot,
and so we exposed this
reagent to our ribosomes,
and now the sarcin-ricin loop is cut.
We throw in the right tRNA,
it goes from the initial state
up to the 0.5, but it
never makes it to 0.75.
And as you see, this little haze up here,
which I'm not sure shows up,
but you see futile attempts
of it going in, it stays
momentarily, but it backs out.
Goes in and backs out.
And so with the sarcin-ricin
loop cut, what we're seeing is
the door isn't fully opened,
it can't really finally
stabilize in the right thing.
And if you compare this to the intact one,
it goes 0.35, 0.5, 0.75,
peptide bond forms.
So we're conjecturing, and
this is wild speculation,
and that's why it's
suitably colored in brown,
that brown is the color of speculation.
That maybe the energy of
hydrolysis is actually used
to supply the conformational
change for the A-loop
that finally opens the
door and lets it go in.
So here we have a really
cute little setup now.
We have first it goes, it checks.
Am I the right one or am I the wrong one?
If it's the right one, fine, it goes in.
You have GTP hydrolysis.
That makes this series of
steps different from that one,
but this is now a series of steps,
where each step is now
magnifying the probability
of picking the right one.
And once you've passed it
through here, you can still
get the wrong people in,
and so after GTP hydrolysis,
it breaks the link of the tRNA
to this sarcin-ricin loop,
so you're testing it
again, but in the meantime,
you're finally opening
the door to let the tRNA
go in for real, permanently.
Before that, the door was only ajar.
And that we see from our FRET data.
So this is the second test.
It's now hanging over here,
but can finally stabilize
over here, it couldn't
even go in here before,
or it can fly away, so
you get to test it again.
The overall fidelity rate at
this magnesium concentration
is a little bit better,
six times 10 minus three.
But remember, we're at 15
millimolar concentration,
a factor of three higher
than what is in E. coli.
We will try to repeat these experiments
at lower concentration,
there are technical reasons,
but we have a faster camera,
we think we can get closer
to physiological solutions.
But it seems to all be there.
Okay, so what have you heard about?
There are two steps,
selection and proofreading.
It starts with the bond
formation, but it's mostly shape,
but it's not only shape,
it's shape magnified
by the reaction of the
bottom part of the ribosome
that then induces this to move to make it
another probability of linking,
right, to the correct thing.
Now you see all those steps are not only
necessary, they're minimal.
You needed GTP hydrolysis,
separates selection
from proofreading, but you're
seeing that GTP hydrolysis
and gaining a stable, saying this step
for the next step simultaneously,
the hydrolysis was needed
to make the two separate,
but it is also finally
opening the door so it can finally go in.
So it's beginning to look
like a minimal number
of steps, very efficient.
Okay, so at this level, I'm
hoping I'm convincing you
that it's beginning look
like chemistry and biology.
Biology is beginning to look
like chemistry and physics.
It's becoming to look very mechanistic.
Okay, because we have these
beautiful high-resolution
structural pictures and a
little bit of motion picture,
and we then link these things together.
So let me come back to what's going on.
Can physics be described by life,
or can life be described by physics?
(audience laughing)
Yes, some graduate students
think there's no life.
And so will we be able to, okay
what is physics really like?
We like universal laws that apply
to all biological organisms.
And you haven't heard
about any universal laws.
Let's talk about what we
mean by universal law.
I would call Kepler's Laws,
let's say the planets go around
the sun in ellipses, as
a phenomenological law.
It's just, you know, that
happens to be they go around
in ellipses, they sweep out
equal areas in equal times.
But universal laws,
let's say Newton's Laws
of Motion and Gravity, because
they apply to all bodies,
to planets, to galaxies,
to apples falling down.
And that's more a universal law,
and you can calculate all sorts of stuff.
So we would ideally like
to have a Newton's Law.
We don't have Kepler's Laws yet either.
Okay, now here are some
common sense things.
By burning energy, you
can do rapid proofreading,
and you can also transport molecules
better than diffusion that way.
And so this you could've guessed,
but we don't understand
these things, we don't,
if you really think you understand it,
you could say at what point
does a biological organism
choose to burn energy
to transport a molecule
or set of molecules from
one position to another
versus letting diffusion take its course.
Proofreading mechanisms.
Here's one that's determined by shape,
not by the strength of chemical bonds.
And it's the shape
discrimination amplified
by these conformational
changes that occur.
Well, it turns out that
probably a lot of proof-making
mechanisms are by shape.
These are some molecular
structures of another enzyme
that can't make mistakes.
This one duplicates DNA.
So here you have your family jewels,
and you want to make a copy of it.
And so you unwind it, and
then on each separate strand,
you wanna put in the complementary bases
so you have an intact piece of DNA
that you can pass down to your children.
And DNA polymerase is
the name of this machine
that makes this, they come
in all shapes and sizes,
but they have roughly the same structure.
And it's a curious little
thing because this thing
has got something that looks like a hand,
a thumb, a finger and something.
And here's the DNA,
and here it's in a mode
where it's looking at the open base
and it reaches in solution
puts in the right one,
and then marches again
and puts in the right one,
so it's replicating.
But it's actually pretty smart,
because it's can sometimes
say no, wrong one put in
there, and it actually
flips into another mode
and says you're not really
supposed to be there, out
you go, and try it again.
So what's it doing?
Well, it's probably looking at the shape.
So put it in, touch it.
Is this, yeah, good fit,
go on to the next one.
And so this is perfect for FRET.
You can put a little thing
here, a little thing here.
Is it really touching or something.
So we'll have a look at this guy.
But looking at the
structures of other things,
RNA polymerase, it's looking like...
It was funny, I was in a
seminar by a graduate student.
He was giving this thing
about what he's found
in the structure of RNA polymerase.
And he was saying, and
here's the structure,
and here's the DNA, and
it seems to be all okay,
but there's nothing in this
machine that's looking at
whether the bases are
doing the right thing.
It too has to make a decision
and put the right base in.
And it only seems to
care about the outside,
and someone the audience said, no,
that doesn't make any intuitive sense,
there's gotta be something it's checking.
And I was sitting there
chuckling and saying,
no, it looks like it's
pretty good, it's the shape.
So maybe it's the shape, who knows.
Okay, so I want to end by saying
that physics is very young,
it's actually only 400 years old.
I would say people like
Galileo were the first
to really combine, experiment
in mathematical models
and really test what's going on.
And so let's talk about
400 years, and let's put it
on a timescale that we can understand.
This is something I took
from a Rich Muller website.
It's actually the temperature of the Earth
looking back 12,000 years.
Here's the temperature of
the Earth as measured by,
let's say, the ratio of
oxygen 16 to oxygen 18,
and the warm parts over
here were good things,
you know, building of
cathedrals and things like that.
The bad parts down here were
bad things like black plague
and things like, but could
have been a coincidence.
And then over here there's a little burp
and then finally it go plunge
down, this was an ice age,
and over here is global warming.
I don't wanna be facetious, there is,
I actually believe
there is global warming.
I'll be glad to take questions on that.
I just want to say that
you notice it's very stable
over here, if you look
back a half million years,
it's wobbling up and down,
it's going from ice age
to warm spots to ice age to warm spots.
But over here you have a very
stable part of the history,
it's really a big stable
part, and right here
is when agriculture started,
maybe also coincidental
that agriculture starts
when the climate stabilizes.
That's where science is, okay,
and this is where maybe
civilization starts.
You have agriculture, you
can have enough free time
to think about other things.
So it's very young and a lot's happened
in the last 400 years.
In fact, a lot's happened
in the last 50 years.
And so you can say, well, what will happen
in the next 40 years?
Well, I'm not gonna live that long,
and mostly people are interested
in what's gonna happen
in the next granting period.
Next three or four years.
But I think you should keep that in mind.
I think there is some clue as to first
the elegance of some of
these biological machines.
I just described two.
But how really elegant they are.
And despite the fact that
you have this huge memory
of evolution that may
not get you, you know,
but you also have
billions of years of time
to refine your mistakes,
now it's also true that
maybe not everything
is the absolute best, it can be optimized
just as the structure
of a city is determined
by its history and not
by some design engineer
with a blank piece of paper.
But in some instances, I
think like the ribosome
at least in this combination process,
it's looking pretty elegant.
Now you can ask even
bolder, crazier questions,
like why is the transfer RNA so big.
The amino acid is a
little thing that's like
the tip of my fingernail,
and there's this big thing
that's bringing it in.
Is it because of history,
biological evolution,
or is there something about
the timescale of the dynamics
that you want it big to make it slow,
because if you want it, because
you need decision-making
time to reject or
accept, and if it's small
and rattling about very rapidly,
then it might be too hard
to design something
that's 10 e-folds away,
it may be easier to design
something that's three
or four e-folds away, but
bigger and just slower to move
so the temp frequency's there.
Who knows, that's wild
speculation, doubly brown.
But why not, we can think about it.
And so in the end, I think,
yes, it's wigglings
and jigglings of atoms,
but as we have these new
probes to look at things
at this molecular point
of view in real time,
I think I'm very hopeful
that we can actually reduce
this stuff to something
that really makes sense.
There is no mystery step anymore.
At least at simple things
like how do we make proteins
or how do we decide what proteins to make
and transcription factors.
Whether we can understand
more complicated things
like how brains work is a different story.
I mean, there's another
project we have in our lab
where we're trying to
understand how neurons
talk to other neurons, but
the detailed molecular thing
of how they really talk
at this mechanistic level.
And from there, if you
can then make things
that so you can bring this,
it's admittedly a big jump
from understanding the
C word, consciousness,
and things like that.
But maybe memory is not so bad.
That I think is within our
realm of our understanding.
But we'll see, so just
wait 40 or 400 years,
and I'll report back to
you if I can, thank you.
(audience applauding)
(gentle electronic music)